[Música]
queridos amigos amigas de visual politic
el plan motosierra del gobierno
libertario de Javier Miley ya está en
marcha este nuevo presidente ha llegado
al gobierno con la intención Clara de
cambiar la Argentina nada de gradualism
ni de tiempos de Espera los cambios ya
están llegando Así que esas son todas
lees que se derogan bueno Obviamente si
se quiere hacer no y después acá tenemos
El Pilón de las leyes que se modif en el
ocaso de 2023 el día 20 de diciembre el
gobierno del presidente Javier Gerardo
milay publicó el decreto
70/2 un decreto que nació con carácter
de urgencia y con el que de la noche a
la mañana derogaron y modificaron más de
300 regulaciones económicas y
administrativas 300 regulaciones que se
fueron al garete de golpe y porrazo
hablamos de una de las aventuras
políticas más trepidantes de la historia
Argentina en el día de hoy he firmado un
decreto de necesidad y urgencia para
comenzar a destrabar este andamiaje
jurídico institucional opresor que ha
destruido nuestro país de esta forma en
vísperas de la Navidad el regalo de mi
lei para los argentinos fue poner en
marcha la demolición de gran parte del
sistema socioeconómico del país gaucho
porque amigos al decreto urgente tenemos
que sumar la conocida como ley
Omnibus hablamos de un documento que el
gobierno argentino le envió al congreso
con más de 180 páginas y 664 cuatro
artículos un documento que nació con la
idea de que el legislativo le reconozca
al gobierno la capacidad de promulgar
directamente un montón de cambios dada
la situación de emergencia pública que
vive el país una pretensión que tal y
como veremos en este vídeo ha levantado
muchas críticas entre la oposición Y es
que si tenemos en cuenta tanto el
decreto inicial como la ley Ómnibus
hablamos de un gigantesco proceso de
liberalización económica que se ha
presentado cuando el presidente
argentino no llevaba ni un mes en el
poder vamos que más que plan motosierra
Casi casi que podríamos conocerlo mejor
como el plan turbos siierra sea como sea
esto ha hecho que en visual politic nos
hagamos unas cuantas preguntas Cómo de
amplio Es realmente este plan de
transformación Qué puede suponer
Exactamente para la Argentina qué
postura tienen los sindicatos y la
oposición Pues todo esto y más lo vamos
a ver a continuación así que ya sabéis
gasolina motor en marcha y arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
bien lo primero que tenemos que hacer
para poder comprender el auténtico
alcance y la profundidad de las medidas
tomadas por Javier Miley es sobrevolar
algunos conceptos jurídicos del país
albiceleste Y es que veréis lo que firmó
el presidente libertario no fue un
simple decreto sino un decreto de
necesidad de urgencia Este es un
instrumento que está recogido en la
propia Constitución Argentina y que le
permita al gobierno aprobar o derogar
por sí mismo normas con Rango de ley en
caso de urgen disminuyendo así las
capacidades del Congreso a ver
lógicamente no es que el gobierno pueda
gobernar a base de decretos saltándose
con ello al congreso sino que estas son
herramientas para situaciones de
emergencia concretamente Esto es lo que
dice el artículo 99 de la Constitución
solamente cuando circunstancias
excepcionales hicieran imposible seguir
los trámites ordinarios previstos por
esta Constitución para la sanción de las
leyes y no se trate de normas que
regulen materia penal tributaria
electoral o de régimen de los partidos
políticos el presidente podrá dictar
decretos por razones de necesidad y
urgencia ahora bien como solemos decir
por aquí hecha la ley hecha la trampa
amigos la Constitución no aclara que es
exactamente una circunstancia
excepcional y claro ya sabéis que los
políticos por muy nuevos y diferentes
que sean siempre siempre suelen saber
cómo torcer el sentido común a su
favor en este caso la lógica detrás del
anuncio de milei y su decreto Es que la
argentina se enfrenta a una crisis
económica absolutamente excepcional una
crisis que justifica la toma de medidas
drásticas y aceleradas es por eso que el
gobierno se vio obligado a usar el
decreto de urgencia fijaos es
imprescindible adoptar medidas que
permitan superar la situación de
emergencia creada por las excepcionales
condiciones económicas y sociales que la
nación padece especialmente como
consecuencia de un conjunto de
decisiones intervencionistas Ojo De
todas formas esto no quiere decir que
aquí el congreso no pinte nada Lo cierto
es que el poder legislativo mantiene la
capacidad de vetar cualquier decreto de
urgencia y de hecho todo esto no es nada
nuevo para el sistema político argentino
de hecho el gobierno de Carlos saull
menem en los 90 hizo un uso más que
intensivo de este instrumento para poder
avanzar así con su ambicioso programa
económico un programa Por cierto que
estaba orientado también
fundamentalmente a la desregulación de
la economía ya sabéis que hablamos de la
Argentina donde eso de liberalizar la
economía suele tener pocos amigos en el
congreso a partir de hoy rompemos La
telaraña de un estado prebendario
asfixiante y arbitrario que trabó la
vida productiva nacional con un conjunto
de innecesarias regulaciones voy a pasar
a enumerar de un modo claro y conciso
cada una de las principales
disposiciones que el poder ejecutivo
nacional ha instrumentado mediante un
decreto de necesidad y urgencia
imprescindible para asegurar el marco de
estabilidad y bien común la cuestión es
que la lógica de gobernar por decretos
siempre tiene ciertos tintes super
presidencialistas y suele generar la
duda de si realmente los gobiernos no se
sobrepasan con ellos Aunque tal y como
vimos tanto el congreso como también en
última instancia la Corte Suprema pueden
limitar su alcance incluso su propia
vigencia pero sea como sea amigos la
cuestión es que este recurso de Miley ha
levantado muchísimas críticas que
cuestionan su legitimidad y de hecho si
os parecen los comentarios podéis
decirnos qué os parece que Miley haya
comenzado así la oleada de cambios que
han preparado para el país No sé creo
que puede ser un debate la mar de
interesante dicho lo cual ahora sí ha
llegado el momento de echar un vistazo a
los cambios
atentos
saluden al Estado que se
[Música]
va si os parece vamos a empezar por lo
más básico las tan temidas
privatizaciones es decir la venta de las
empresas públicas que la verdad suelen
tener más agujeros que aun queso gruer
Pues bien Esto es algo que en Argentina
supone un esfuerzo titánico entre otras
cosas porque las empresas públicas del
Estado no son Realmente compañías
mercantiles al uso sino que tienen un
estatus especial son sociedades del
Estado una categoría especial que
establece el único dueño posible es
precisamente el propio estado y que hace
que sus trabajadores en la práctica sean
básicamente trabajadores públicos
prácticamente funcionarios por eso el
primer paso para privatizar estas
empresas pasa por convertirlas en
sociedades anónimas con todo lo que ello
conlleva y de hecho este fue
precisamente uno de los puntos clave del
decreto de urgencia de mi ley ocho
derogación de la normativa que impide la
privatización de las empresas públicas
nueve derogación del régimen de
sociedades del Estado 10 transformación
de todas las las empresas del estado en
sociedades anónimas para su posterior
privatización Claro que una vez hecho
este cambio Ahora toca lo más difícil
encontrar un comprador que esté
dispuesto a quedarse con empresas que
por lo general son deficitarias poco
productivas tienen trabajadores
cabreados y corren el riesgo para col
modo de que en el futuro pues Un
gobierno de otro color pueda volver a
cambiar las reglas de
juego a ver pensadlo bien entre los
sindicatos la oposición las protestas y
los beneficios laborales privatizar en
la Argentina puede llegar a ser tan
fácil como enseñar a bailar tango a un
oso polar y eso por no hablar de los
compradores que Seguro seguro se
terminarán haciendo una pregunta En qué
lío me estoy metiendo Pues bien El caso
es que entre las empresas a las que
pronto le
colgarnos ipf que en cierto modo es una
excepción Aunque eso sí con algunos
matices Y es que veréis desde que el
gobierno la nacionalizar en el año 2012
esta compañía ha mejorado sus números
gracias fundamentalmente a vaca muerta
pero ahora el estado puede tener que
pagar la friolera de 16,000 millones de
dólares en indemn iciones lo que hace
que la operación haya sido una auténtica
ruina La pregunta es tendrán que asumir
los compradores este enorme pago la vez
para entender el fallo contra la
Argentina por la expropiación de ipf una
jueza de los Estados Unidos le dio la
razón al demandante y señaló que fueron
perjudicados por la estatización de 2012
al no realizar una oferta por las
acciones que poseían en la compañía la
magistrada aceptó el cálculo de
intereses reclamado por lo que
especialistas estiman que el país deberá
pagar cerca de 16,000 millones de
dólares de indemnización luego otra
empresa que parece que va a ser
privatizada Próximamente es aerolíneas
argentinas que cuenta con uno de los
sindicatos más radicalizados de todo el
país Si se quiere cargar aerolíneas
argentinas nos va a tener que matar
amenaza a mi ley y posterior marcha
atrás del principal sindicalista
aeronáutico Claro que un momento por
cara al gobierno No solo está planteando
deshacerse de las empresas públicas sino
que tampoco mantendrá muchos de los
beneficios que reciben a algunos
sectores productivos hablamos por
ejemplo de bonificaciones Fiscales
créditos a tipos ventajosos subsidios o
restricciones de entrada al sector entre
otros Pues bien eso se
acabó la idea es que a partir de ahora
todas las empresas compitan con las
mismas reglas ni privilegios ni ventajas
seis derogación de la ley de promoción
Industrial siete derogación de la ley de
promoción comercial 15 derogación de las
obligaciones de los ingenios azucareros
tienen en materia de producción
azucarera 16 liberación del régimen
jurídico aplicable del sector
vitivinícola eso sí lo cierto Es que
todas las agrupaciones empresariales del
país han respaldado el cambio sobre todo
seducidas por una promesa de mi ley
llevar a cabo la gran reforma laboral y
amigos ese pulso ya ha comenzado y vaya
pulso
[Música]
atentos en la cueva del
león queridos amigos aquí en visual
politic ya os hemos hablado varias veces
del inmenso poder que tienen los
sindicatos argentinos durante años y los
sindicatos querían en la Argentina no se
movía ni un solo dedo Claro que en los
últimos tiempos ese poder incontestable
casi extorsivo ha comenzado a ser
duramente criticado especialmente por
dos cosas porque los sindicatos se han
convertido básicamente en un brazo
político del
preisoep hasta convertirse mucha
diferencia en la institución peor
valorada de toda la Argentina ni el fmi
ni los bancos ni los medios de
comunicación suscitan tanto rechazo
hablamos de que siete de cada 10
argentinos tienen una mala o muy mala
imagen de los sindicatos algo que por
supuesto le facilita mucho las cosas a
mi ley cuanto menos populares sean los
sindicatos mejor que mejor para poder
llevar a cabo su ambiciosa reforma
laboral pues bien De momento con el
decreto de urgencia ya se han hecho
varias cosas por ejemplo se han ampliado
los periodos de prueba para nuevos
empleados se han introducido nuevos
mecanismos voluntarios de indemnización
por despidos y cosas por el estilo pero
con todo el verdadero golpe de efecto
viene con la suspensión de los conocidos
Como bloqueos
sindicales Y es que veréis en Argentina
por mucho que os pueda sorprender cuando
un sindicato quería presionar una
empresa para conseguir nuevos beneficios
laborales o una mejora salarial una
medida que habitualmente utilizaban era
la de bloquear las entradas y salidas de
los centros de trabajo forzando con ello
la paralización absoluta de la actividad
productiva ojo quisieran o no los
empleados de la propia empresa y eso es
lo que explicaba noticias como estas el
sindicato de camioneros de moyano
bloquea depósitos de Mercado libre y
peligra la entrega de productos sancor
alertó por un bloqueo sindical que pone
en riesgo 3 millones de litros de leche
Santa Cruz por un bloqueo gremial las
pesqueras están paradas y las mineras
amenazan con irse a operar a Chile Pues
bien ahora todas estas noticias son
historia el decreto de urgencia aprobado
por milei ha establecido que este tipo
de acciones son ilegales y sancionables
a partir de ahora en la Argentina será
una falta grave cualquier acción que
afecte a la libertad de trabajar de los
empleados que no quieran sumarse a una
huelga y también será ilegal cualquier
acción que impida u obstruya el acceso a
las empresas o por supuesto cualquier
acción que cause algún daño por supuesto
como os podéis imaginar esto ha hecho
que los grandes gremios sindicales
pongan el grito en el cielo según ellos
mi ley está criminalizando el derecho a
la huelga lo que les ha llevado a
convocar una huelga general el 24 de
enero Aunque qué queréis que os diga lo
único que ha hecho el gobierno de milei
es no criminalizar que un trabajador
pueda trabajar si no está de acuerdo con
una huelga lo que por otra parte tendría
que ser un derecho esencial no os parece
Eso sí por ahora la cámara nacional de
apelaciones del trabajo de la Argentina
ha dictado la suspensión de la sección
del decreto que abordaba las reformas
laborales dejando así la definición
final en manos de la Corte
Suprema luego otro actor que también
está siendo clave en medio de toda la
tensión que se está Desatando son los
denominados movimientos sociales y Qué
son los movimientos sociales Pues
básicamente organizaciones que pret
tienden a aglutinar a los beneficiarios
de los planes sociales Como por ejemplo
los subsidios por desempleo o la
asignación universal por hijo estas
organizaciones exigen cada dos por tres
aumentos en los pagos y más planes
sociales y la pregunta es cómo lo hacen
Pues con protestas y cortes en las
principales arterias viales del país
haciendo especial énfasis en los accesos
a la capital a Buenos Aires Pues bien
Ahora el gobierno ha comunicado que la
participación en esta clase de
actividades ilegales se sancionará con
la pérdida del plan social o el subsidio
de todos aquellos que corten las vas
públicas informamos que todos aquellos
que hayan promovido instigado organizado
o participado de los cortes perderán
todo tipo de diálogo con el Ministerio
de capital humano los únicos que no van
a cobrar el plan son los que vayan a la
marcha y corte en la calle ya lo dijo el
presidente el que corta no cobra
queridos amigos amigas durante meses se
puso en duda que Javier Miley pudiera
mantener la gobernabilidad en un país
acostumbrado a las protestas masivas
Pues bien por ahora el presidente lamos
mostrado sus cartas se acabó eso de
agitar las calles y paralizar por la
fuerza del país y amigos todo esto ha
ocurrido en poco más de un mes en el
gobierno y con las fiestas de Navidad y
Año Nuevo de por medio ya os dije antes
que el nuevo gobierno ha llegado con
ganas de jugar el partido y ahora la
oposición está trinchera en el congreso
un lugar donde los libertarios han
comenzado a librar la madre de todas las
batallas Y es que el gobierno argentino
necesita en primer lugar que el
parlamento no anule el decreto de
urgencia Y en segundo lugar que apruebe
su ley Omnibus La pregunta es será esto
posible pues
atentos la madre de todas las
batallas el paquete de medidas
anunciadas por mi ley en el decreto de
urgencia es tan amplio que aquí tan solo
hemos visto algunos puntos muy concretos
casi que podemos decir que el decreto le
arruinó las fiestas navideñas no solo a
la oposición sino también a todos los
juristas del país abogados jueces y todo
tipo de expertos legales sí me da que
para el peronismo mi lei se convirtió en
el auténtico Grinch en este sentido
amigos gran parte de la validez del
decreto de urgencia quedará en manos de
la Corte Suprema que en las próximas
semanas Seguramente se pronunciará sobre
muchos de sus puntos comenzó la batalla
judicial por la vigencia del dnu de
Javier Miley se presentó el primer
Amparo piden su nulidad por constituir
una desviación de poder y un abuso de
derecho público por violar el principio
republicano la división de poderes la
democracia el principio de reserva de
ley y los derechos colectivos de la
ciudadanía Argentina a la participación
en la dirección de los asuntos públicos
directamente o a través de sus
representantes los antecedentes de la
Corte Suprema son adversos para el meade
decreto de Javier Miley el máximo
tribunal tiene un criterio muy
restrictivo para convalidar esta
facultad del poder ejecutivo debe
establecerse un auténtico estado de
necesidad de urgencia y una
imposibilidad legislativa ahora bien al
margen de todo este asunto de la
judicialización del decreto la prioridad
del Congreso Argentino no es analizar la
ley Omnibus una ley que sirve como
complemento al decreto y que pone su
atención en otras muchas reformas de
Gran calibre Así que si os parece
repasemos Cuáles son las principales
propuestas incorporadas por mi ley a
este proyecto de
[Música]
ley por ejemplo Hablamos de una reforma
electoral que planteaba eliminar las
paso esto es las primarias abiertas
simultáneas y obligatorias esto dejaría
en manos de cada partido decidir la
fórmula para escoger a sus propios
candidatos luego además se plantea
instaurar en todo el país una modalidad
de circunscripciones uninominales para
la elección de los diputados nacionales
un cambio donde las provincias menos
pobladas pues tendrían menos
representantes por otro lado la ley
contempla también una amnistía fiscal
para todos aquellos que buscaron
esconder sus ingresos durante el
gobierno de Alberto Fernández Esta
medida permitirá regularizar hasta
00,000 en efectivo inmuebles o
criptomonedas sin tener que pagar
impuestos también se reforma el esquema
de la obra pública para que los planes
de infraestructura sean financiados por
fondos privados abriendo incluso la
posibilidad de rencio enciar o rescindir
los contratos que están en ejecución Por
otra parte se elimina la conocida como
movilidad jubilatoria de tal forma que
sea El Ejecutivo quien establezca una
nueva modalidad para el cálculo de los
reajustes periódicos y automáticos de
las pensiones se contempla Asimismo la
efectiva privatización de 41 empresas
públicas entre ellas la empresa de
correo público ipf el Banco Nacional y
la empresa de telecomunicaciones del
estado y también se creará un mercado de
carbono y se establecerán controles a
las emisiones Pues bien Esto es
principalmente lo que contiene la ley
Omnibus Eso sí aunque ley prometió
defender A capa y espada sus reformas
dentro del Congreso Lo cierto es que la
bancada libertaria está en Clara minoría
lo que lógicamente la ha obligado a
tener que negociar con bloques no
peronistas para poder reunir los votos
suficientes y aprobar al menos en la
cámara baja el proyecto de ley y es que
llegados hasta aquí creo que todos
podemos entender la enorme la gigantesca
dimensión que tiene la apuesta que ha
hecho Javier
Miley en primer lugar tenemos el decreto
que modifica hace un plumazo años de
regulaciones y restricciones a la
actividad económica ahora las dudas
sobre su legalidad se fundamentan en que
no existe una necesidad de urgencia
reconocida en el país pero justo aquí es
donde entra la ley Omnibus que sirve Más
allá de las reformas complementarias que
hemos comentado para que el congreso
valide la consideración del estado de
emergencia Así que si milei logra que la
mayoría del legislativo le otorgue ese
respaldo es prácticamente imposible que
la Corte Suprema tumbe tanto el decreto
como la propia ley Omnibus en resumidas
cuentas que la jugada de mi ley es osada
en pocas semanas su gobierno puede tener
una victoria histórica o sufrir una gran
derrota política y Judicial nada más
comenzar su mandato sea como sea amigos
La motosierra está en marcha y los
libertarios ya están enseñando su carta
final en el caso de que los planes no
salgan como esperan caso de que se ha
rechazado en el tiempo no llamarías una
consulta popular un plebiscito
Obviamente que me expliquen Por qué
digamos los digamos Por qué el congreso
se pone en contra de algo que le hace
bien a la gente queridos amigos y amigas
de visual politic nos puede gustar más o
menos lo que Miley está haciendo y las
formas que está utilizando pero lo
cierto Es que Miley está haciendo
exactamente lo que prometió rechazar
cualquier tipo de gradualismo e ira por
todas y sabéis Qué es que incluso el
propio Mauricio macri considera ahora
que ese enfoque del gradualismo era
equivocado No lame gradualismo una forma
elegante de ocultar La debilidad
política que tenía que cualquier cosa
mandaba al al al la cámara de diputados
pedía un un pollo y me mandaban una
pluma de los ciudadanos de esa creencia
de que los políticos son seres
superiores que deben regir los destinos
de cada uno de nosotros se desprende un
ameia institucional que hace que nadie
pueda trabajar comerciar circular o
educarse sin el permiso de
ellos así están las cosas en la
Argentina y este es exactamente el
camino de demolición y reconstrucción
que ha planteado el nuevo presidente un
presidente conocido ya como el león
argentino pero ahora llegado hasta aquí
la pregunta es para ti qué opinas del
plan milei Te parece bien intentar sacar
todas las reformas de golpe crees que la
ley Omnibus será Finalmente aprobada y
mi ley se saldrá con la suya déjanos
como siempre tus impresiones en los
comentarios y habramos de y ahora si
este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darle al botón de like y
suscribiros a visual politic si es que
aún no lo habéis hecho una vez más
Muchas gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la
próxima